[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you guys
no man like
i literally corrected the other one and
now all of a sudden it doesn't want to
work
yeah it's
did it did it
can you guys hear me
let me see
i think they can can the stream hear me
no audio come on man
hold on
yeah hey
uh
yeah hey
they heard me someone i'm in the stream
too yeah i'm in the uh youtube mad
issues mad issues this is what we get
for relying on you know relying on on
technology so much man this is what we
get for line of technology i appreciate
everyone coming out for the attic show
where we discuss the past president
future of gaming i'm not going to be
able to really tell who's talking who
because for some reason
my mixer is messed up it says no one's
talking but we're going to move right
past that because there's been enough
issues with technology this week so i'm
here
with hustle and motivate what's going on
hustle
ah not too much it's um it's tuesday and
um technology still thinks that it's
monday so you know what you know we just
gotta let it rock out man you know the
nice holiday was a cool little holiday
for me um considering what happened
which i put on twitter a tree hit the
back of my garage so yeah there's a hole
in the roof
oh there's a hole in the oh god yes sir
i hate that man man
there's nothing worse than a hole in the
roof man i hope that all works out for
you man but
volume is too low
i i could turn it up man but
like as far as cause i can't see
let me see if i can hustle squats that's
why i wanted to check my own audio
that's why i got here early but that's
not your fault oh hold on can i raise
myself up
all right so try try talking now
okay hey ladies and gentlemen people
should be fine now hopefully people
should be fine i don't know i can't see
people's mixer i put it up almost max
oh my audio attic is good it sounds fine
on my end
um hustle's audio is a little bit low
see if i turn myself up i'ma start
peeking so i don't want to do that it's
i gotta figure out is there a way in
here to turn me up
hustle motivate let me
nope
oh my how low is he let me okay he said
he's better now better now
technical issues man i don't know what's
going on my computer's actually running
fine right now it's it's
it seems like it's it's just it's obs
maybe obs is messing up because my
computer but we're not gonna badge on
that too much man we're going to talk
about we got some good
topics as you can see we're going to
talk about that sony ps5 tax that sony
always be making you play for being a
loyalist and being a day one purchaser
addict is too loud
yeah you went up a little bit and i'm
not sure why
i don't know man i don't know let me put
my mac back a little bit
it isn't too loud i can live with it
all right all right look i turned
everything down man i don't have a mixer
i can't see things man i can't see
things
i can't see who's talking and who's not
talking
see what i'll show you guys this is what
it looks like right now on my screen as
you can see usually right here it tells
you who's talking and like the the
engages and it's not doing none of that
it's just like
everything
is going to be
blake but we're going to move right past
that man we're going to talk about the
the sony ps5 taxes uh and whether i
still
i still feel away on what's going on but
it does look like there is some some
improvement going on in the taxes of of
playstation charging its loyal customers
and day one purchasers that ten dollar
tax then we're going to talk about which
i didn't that that that alan wait going
to ps5 that's not supposed to be there i
guess what happened is i uh
what i had to keep doing
because uh
for those of you that just got here i
like i had a lot of issues
being
bought by xbox so let me go and fix that
real quick so then we're going to talk
about
this rumor going around that maybe take
two's been bought by xbox i know that
sounds crazy we're not going to get too
much into that yet we'll get to that
later and then we're going to talk about
our playstation showcase prediction show
addict before we get started turn
yourself down a little bit that's coming
from uh i believe cognito
so i'm looking at the chat as um
i'm interacting with the chat and
everything and they just ask you to turn
yourself down just a tad bit all right i
i think i i turned it down
i don't know we're going to see how it
sounds i apologize for all of the tech
issues guys man sometimes it just
happens there's nothing we could do
about it see i am so like crazy right
now
i didn't even retweet the show because i
was trying to fix the show are you
slipping slipping i been put that out
there sir look i can't help it i can't
help i cannot help that the streaming
part was not working turn it down some
more look man uh people are saying it's
good i'ma just
i'ma just put the mic back a little bit
more look you know obviously we're gonna
talk about what i personally i want to
keep stuff realistic i want to snatch a
little bit of that swag from cognito and
ass hustle something he does not want to
see at this playstation 5 showcase and
that's that's that's what i want to go
through man but let's go and talk about
the sony ps5 tax man you know obviously
we see stuff going on right now you're
peeking you got to fix it how am i
peeking i can't
the mixer is so low though man like
people tell me peeking [ __ ] saying it's
fine
i'm so confused
let me get my phone hold up hold up i'ma
call you guys out right now hold up no
no attic you are kind of peeking a
little bit i had to turn you up a little
bit because i don't have
all right yeah i can see how i can peek
a little bit all right all right
yeah so let me go ahead and turn this
volume down just a little bit now i
don't i don't want to i i get it's fine
let's move on but we don't want to be
crackling in people's ears the whole
podcast so hopefully that'll fix uh
going things into that man let's first
off let's talk about the sony ps5 tags
now obviously
we are seeing what's going on right now
with the infamous
horizon zero dawn
i believe it was horizon dawn where
originally they they said that if you
get the ps4 version you're gonna get the
ps5 version free but then they
they did it they did a 180 and said
we lied and then they did another 180.
so i guess technically they did a 360.
and now they're saying yo we're going to
honor what we did previously now
hustle
hustle
yes sir why can't we have this energy
when ghost sushima happened
hey you got me that was one of the first
things that i thought is they're gonna
go back on that why can't they go back
on on it all like listen man
this wouldn't even be an issue if they
did if they implemented what microsoft
implements in terms of the smart
delivery this wouldn't be an issue at
all it would just be all right it worked
on ps4 i coolest upgraded the ps5
no fuss no must that's hitting that saw
everybody because like the
the part that bothers me is that
everybody can't get their hands on the
ps5 just yet like you already know the
game man the scalpel is going to tell
them joining stuff the bot's gonna go
ahead and get all them ps5 so just make
it easier for people to transition over
uh it shouldn't have to be brought twice
um before they went back and kind of
corrected themselves and all the
playstation fans were celebrating shout
out to them before they did that the
only way that you could have it carried
across both systems was through the
digital deluxe version and there was
like a two hundred dollar version i
think that was a collective suggestion
and the other version there was an 80
version you had to do too wasn't there
yeah that's that's so good so they
didn't even have a 70 version to get a
ps5 version
well i'm assuming this the 70 dollar one
would have been the standard one
not the
was the standard 170 so hold up
so let me get this
the 70 version that's the ps5 version
that wouldn't come with the ps4 version
too
i'm kind of confused how
only the 80 version has both because if
the standard version was the 71 and
that's the ps5 one to me that should
come with both does that make sense to
you like
it does but the way that they switched
everything up it kind of
they was on their wild mode i know the
only way that you could have both
versions is if you had the digital
version which was for 80 i do believe
and one of those collectors editions i
and um you might have to correct me if
i'm wrong didn't like the 230 version i
forget what it's called the name is on
top of my tongue which i can't really
pronounce it but didn't that version
that come with anything at all so you
know what we're gonna do because yes sir
uh i don't really i've never really
cared about like collector's editions
and stuff so let me
uh let me look here real quick we're
going to look up it would be the
pre-order list wasn't it
yeah
they probably would have changed all
this by now
i think they did because well i was
going to get i got the 200
collectors edition and it has ps4 slash
ps5 on it now i'm not sure i think that
one was always like that but i think
they put a little message in there now
that was like your ps4 version will work
on the ps5 so there's no need to upgrade
i remember seeing that as well i wish i
could find a link
that shows the older stuff i'm sure it's
on here somewhere yeah i'm not going to
really go look for that but
oh oh and there's no disc afropunk says
there's no discs in the 200 version
apparently that's what he says i don't
know i didn't look at that it only came
with the digital version so
that's crazy man like can we please keep
what look
i've always said it doesn't matter what
it doesn't matter who you are it doesn't
matter what company you are these
companies can get this work
they can get this work indeed and what
i'm enjoying what i'm seeing
is for the most part
everyone had that same mentality
everyone they're going to get this work
i didn't see too many people whatsoever
having issues on what was going on
because to me it's like look like
you're not rewarding to like look it's
like i asked king the iop we had uh
hustle
to me you're charging ten dollar fees to
unlock
updates that's in the ps5 that they
marketed with the console to me it feels
like sony's low-key punishing first uh
first adopters
because it's just like okay okay so i
you i am a loyal fan i went out and i
spent that 500
and i went out there and i got that
i actually personally went through hell
to get my playstation 5. they what's the
what's the things that they promoted
also what's the thing they promoted with
that ps5 the the hybrid feedback
whatever it is the
3d audio and then it's like they come in
the back door like oh but if you want to
use the stuff we promoted we needed a
ps5 tax
like we need that
and it was so crazy even like the fact
that you i would even have because i
have a ps5 as well but the fact that i
would even have to pay extra for
something of that magnitude like bro
that's like me getting a new graphics
card they said oh wait you know if you
want to use the features on your your
new uh rtx 3090 or whatever it is you
want to use the ray tracing feature yeah
you got to pay for that
we need an extra five dollars from your
extra ten dollars from you if you want
to use the new stuff that's implemented
in your new hallway so that's
oh boy let me ask you a question yes do
you think
i know this isn't exactly like apples to
apples but to me
it's like equivalent of microsoft
charging for auto hdr
and an auto boost mode it's like look
like if you want to use these features
that we put into rnr uh you know into
research and development we want that
money and like to me it's like you know
you should have incentive to move to
these platforms without being nickel and
dime once you get to these platforms
absolutely um and it's you know and you
said it earlier it's like we're being
punished and i do want to respond to uh
someone in the chat nobody's crying
about ten dollars though it's not even
that but if i spend someone said oh yo
vg vg is a boss he said still defending
ten times the facts like yo bro i spent
530 on my costume dog and
for the record i could afford it quite
easily but that's not it's not the point
it's not the point man it's just the
fact that if i have new hardware
and all the stuff that's implemented in
my new hallway should work no problem
that's it that's it and that's all like
it's no argument to even be had at that
point like why would i i would have just
stayed on the ps4 it's like at that
point you know what where where's the
line or you know
were they going to
do they have the consideration you know
maybe we should charge to use the ssd
like
when you launch the game they're like yo
i need a dollar to play this this play
through we're gonna charge you 199 to
use this ssd like it's just like at this
point man
we got to call them out there should be
no reason they're doing this and anyone
defending it it's not about it's only
ten dollars it's about the fact that
you shouldn't have to pay that you
should have to be one of those things
where it's like you know i've always
been a
a far person when it comes to cross
generation games
if it's after the game came out it's a
little bit more acceptable not
necessarily should you know they should
still definitely do it because to me if
you're buying that ps5 sony should
respect you enough because you are a day
one adopter your day your adopter and
they're like yo we got you you over here
we got you oh you want that ps5 version
we got you there should be no
because to me it really does feel like
they're punishing their day one adopters
like that is the the ride and die people
and they're wanting more money from them
and that's why i
i was so happy with the
the outrage that happened with this
horizon zero dawn or how horizon
forbidden west i don't know what the
damn horizon forbidden west yeah okay
horizon forbidden west like
oh it's coming
you know
this isn't the first time that that
we've seen this and we kind of need to
take this as a lesson you remember when
uh xbox tried to raise the price of
gamepad or gold to try to get people to
migrate over the game pace
yes
and everyone came together on that
everybody everyone came together
everybody and um i had had you know
poked my head into a few uh twitter
spaces yesterday i don't know who was
defending that cuz like for the people
who i follow and i consider them a
hardcore playstation and xbox guys and
nintendo people right i don't know who
was defending that but it was like oh
some people are defending nobody nobody
who i saw personally was like defending
what um sony was doing in fact a lot of
people a lot of people who i i rock with
who i see on the timeline they don't
really like the the leadership that's
going on over there right now and i'm
gonna be real with you i can't blame you
it's a lot of whole it's a lot of
misdirection this
you know smoke and mirrors it seems like
it's a lot of smoke and mirrors
it's like crazy it's like nine life save
like ubisoft's giving free upgrades
there's a lot of companies giving free
upgrades like you know it's the same
thing with the seventy dollar price tag
that says sony's not the one that
originated this sony's not the only one
charging seventy dollars it really feels
like sony's one of the only companies
charging for next-gen upgrades sure
there are other companies doing it like
oh yeah call of duty i'm pretty sure
it's probably going to do it most likely
but you know microsoft's not doing it it
seems like ubisoft's not doing it
there's a bunch of companies not doing
it so why are we letting sony be the odd
ones out like i get it you know they
don't have to do that but damn that we
consumers we don't give a [ __ ] what they
have to do with business like like we
want what's best for us as the consumers
and then charging us
six look i've always been one of those
things if i bought a game
post ps4
and then they made an update later i
want that free
because i bought that before the ps5
came out and i picked up your ps5 if i
picked up horizon zero dawn later
horizon forbidden west or
i'm pretty sure that's what it is if i
pick that up after i bought the ps5 for
the whole 70 that's different
but to me i didn't get the choice to
pick it up to 70 in the ps4 era when i
went over to the ps5
i feel like you already bought the copy
we're not going to charge you more
because you did buy that game so we're
just going to give you that free update
but if you ain't bought that game i have
no problem with them snatching that ps4
version off the store and charging 70
for that updated director's cut but to
charge the people who already own the
game to use the features of the ps5 they
bought is where i draw the line
yeah um and the reason why you know i
want to i do kind of want to go back on
what i said earlier the gosha shushima
thing at least they could they could
hear that a little bit because that was
a whole expansion that came with that so
that's why that that blow didn't really
hit us hard but this one is essentially
unless i'm incorrect and i want somebody
to correct me this is essentially the
same game on the ps4 that it is on the
ps5 there's no there is no difference
here so i'm like yeah there's no need
man and um and i brought it up earlier
yo we need to stand up for a lot of
these things and the second we all come
together and like get some type of like
you know unity going and we could change
a whole lot
like i i never saw
like a company just
do it they did a 180 in like 24 hours
because i think they released it and i
think i think the last time i saw that
was microsoft with the 360 thing like
yeah they did that pretty fast too
yup and that and that again and i still
think that was like a i'm be real but i
got my conspiracy theorist head on i
think that they knew that this was going
to cause the outrage and i think that
they were they were ready to kind of
fall back on that same thing with
microsoft i think that they knew that
xbox gold thing was going to cause the
outrage and they they already had it
planned i think they just kind of wanted
to
that's just my conspiracy theories um my
thoughts and uh ideas uh don't represent
the iron laws podcast i just don't you
know i don't wanna make sure i get you
on trumpet so i gotta put that
disclaimer
in case you ain't noticed
you know we we have some
we have some crazy takes man
you know and no one no one's ever gonna
like you know take that those takes away
because that's why a lot of people trust
us they're like they know
that when we give our opinions on
something it's genuine it's not one of
those things where you know we're we're
switching up in our opinion because a
certain crowd wants to it's just like
you get what you get on here you uh when
you watch the iron lords podcast you can
almost guarantee that for the most part
king going to
do whatever he can to make the xbox
brand look good and then sometimes
you'll come in and he'll surprise you
and he'll completely do a 360. oh he's
like no that's not good see that's how
you know king is a real one because when
it comes to the actual real negative
stuff on xbox king is saying i don't
like this this needs to change
and you know we need more of that kind
of you know we need more of that we need
more everyone come together
it's just like you know me and kid
smooth went at it because i personally
felt like they should have delayed the
um
the whole actually it's all been halo
infinite like okay so would halo
infinite first was shown i said this
game needs to be delayed kids who said
no doesn't need to be delayed so then
when it gets delayed kids move is still
holding his ground saying it shouldn't
have been delayed and that's fine not
gonna
kid wants to play i understand the hype
for playing something like that but to
me
my biggest thing is like i want the game
to be the best it can and i was
convinced that microsoft was about to
use hagel infinite as a sacrificial lame
to have a launch title for the
xbox series x i was convinced i didn't
think they would ever delay that because
i thought their thought process was it
is more beneficial for the series x to
have a launch title of halo than it is
for halo to be a good good game and
that's what my issue was and thank god
they delayed it because i feel like you
know i still feel like they should need
to delay the game again i was going i
was going to because
yeah because there's some feature but
it's like i said
the game isn't missing you know core
things in the game it's missing features
of those things
you know for instance it's still got the
single player you just can't play with
other people
i can't you know as much as i want to
play with other people
what's it i can't go about and say that
sorry about that bless you
i can't go and say that
kid smooth has no right to play that
because i want to play that with other
people
so it's just like look you'll still have
access to all these but you're going to
have to play them on your own terms you
can't play them you know with other
people you're gonna have to play them
the way they want you to play them but i
get it it sucks and i personally feel
like the game will do better if it's
delayed because i want this game to
review well i want this game to have his
best
foot going forward as possible and to me
having certain features
of it missing is going to hurt that so i
i and i was like i said i was one of
those people needs a delight needs the
light kid smooth on top of twitter with
the with the with the guns man no it
doesn't like and it's just like look
like
we always gotta look at what's
beneficial to us
i can understand the halo infinite
because halo infinite isn't necessarily
beneficial to anyone halo is going to be
halo regardless if you could play with
two people or four people just go to
hyphen the experience
so i can understand fighting over that
one but a company trying to sell sell me
pieces of a console that they marketed
the hell out of and then when i get the
console because they market all you you
know haptic feedbacks they're going to
be great and then when i get the damn
thing they're like oh we want that ten
dollars you can't use none of that [ __ ]
so like
that's where we need to take a stand
so
how do you feel about what's going on
horizon zero dawn and what was your
thought process also when all this went
down
i'm gonna be real with you
the first time i was on the iron laws
podcast we spoke about 70 dollar games i
told y'all back then i told y'all back
then episode 165 i said yo there is no
need for this because there are more
gamers now than there ever have been it
shouldn't been a highest price in the
first place because now we're running
into a situation like this
i shouldn't i feel like i shouldn't be
charged an extra ten dollars just
because i want the superior experience
um
like again like i feel like it's
i don't want to say this against the law
now i want to say it's criminal because
there are criminal acts going on but
it's
this is like the craziest thing to me um
i i don't i don't understand like i
don't get it man like i don't know
who's doing what over there
over there sony man but
all right look
i'm gonna buy it because it's the same
price on the collector's edition is the
same price on ps4 as it is on ps5
i would be upset if i was paying a
different price not paying 200 for it
you know just you know for the record
i'm paying 200 for it
i'm okay with that it's not about
crowding about the ten dollars like yo
what if
just what if you just bought a ps5 and
you just wasn't expecting that that type
of move like you oh like the reason main
reason why i got a ps5 but you can't see
them behind me now but all my ps4 games
work on the joint can you imagine if i
had to pay ten dollars for an upgrade
for all of the games that i paid for so
all the games that i played that'd get
costly
and if you think about it i think that
straining had it didn't it the new the
directors got death stranding that's it
now i don't know but i i don't know if
they've officially said that or anything
but to me i guess director's cut just
looked negative
as hell to me now so i just
automatically assume it might not have
it but we see now that that not only
were they trying to get that extra ten
dollars from horizon but it looks like
you know they might have actually tried
to go a little bit beyond that and it's
like if you want the boat you have to
pay eighty dollars so yeah it's just
like look like at the end of the day we
understand people are excited for this
and we're never going to take that from
you i've always said multiple times on
this show
you could still support something that
you don't agree with
but it doesn't mean you could silence
yourself in actually stating you don't
agree with it
um i want to say this before before we
move on i'm a pc gamer for for those for
the you know your audience who may not
know me very well i do game on pc i got
a lot of this stuff through uh game pass
for free well not for free but i paid a
little fee for it and i also gained a
lot of my games on sting
it's the it's the digital thing that
bothers me this is coming from a pc
gamer like for me
i have horizon zero dawn right on ps4
i also have it on pc shout out to my boy
melodic punk for actually gifting that
for me for my birthday
i'm a big collector on physical things i
literally just bought a nintendo 64 just
to play the old stuff now i don't mind
it so much but i always want to be able
to go back and play whatever games that
i want to play just in case god forbid
if something were to happen to my steam
account i don't got access to horizon no
more but you know why i got it
right on ps4 like i got the physical
version right on ps4 so for every
digital version of a game that i have i
go back and get a physical one that's
why i was i was i was definitely
bothered by just at first that digital
game just working on both platforms but
the physical game now you had to pay to
pay for the upgrade like nah that's
that's that's
i'm not gonna curse i'm not incredibly
that's not cool let me just say that
that's not cool
and it's like look man we just want a
better product in general
uh you know i know there's this big
statement going around this is xbox
people don't call that microsoft for the
lack of quality games which is which is
horse [ __ ] i'm gonna be real with you we
always do
it's like at the end of the day if you
don't watch these content creators and
their content they put out there in the
podcast that they do how are you gonna
say that we don't call people out for
anything
i i you know i got jumped on because i
felt like
they needed to do more with starfield at
the last e3 i said look you this game's
been hyped up for years sure maybe not
all by microsoft but almost every time
you talk to phil spencer they're saying
how hyped they are for starfield but
when we see star
it's 30 seconds
so like and i get it next year the
game's not coming out this year so it's
more beneficial and it makes more sense
to do a full-blown gameville reveal next
year and i know the only reason that
starfield was at this event is because
they wanted to have those magical words
come out starfields and exclusive and i
think that's the only reason that it was
at this event but you know
trying to move on a little bit because
we do got this
take two being bought by xbox
okay no this is a crazy topic and
keep in mind everybody when i say
with uh what k uh what does that say
uh what
take this with a grain of salt or
something like that yes
like the whole canister like i want you
guys to take that whole salt and put it
on a paper
on a plate because this is far-fetched
now normally i would never believe this
in a million years and i don't believe
it it's like a 25 chance and the only
reason i'm giving the 25 chance is
because i said the same thing about
bethesda when they bought them
so like i'm going to give them a little
bit of 25 man that 25 chance that it
would happen but
there's no way this is happening i it's
just like you got to think about a gta 5
gta by itself is a billion dollar
franchise
and then you got
i mean they do own a lot take two
they have a lot of stuff
like and i guess
take two would be a really good company
to buy because
imagine the games that would be
they
it would be a wrap
like it's just like
part of me wants this to happen because
i want to see the world burn i want to
see that twitter streets that day i want
to see people had like man
jack but where's the wii live yet like
let's go why i gotta see me
if
microsoft bought take two interactive
what do you think the initial reaction
in the community in our immediate
community would be hustle
oh oh no but xbox we getting xbox we get
the xbox one x we getting the xbox
series s series x we building pcs they
doing all that dawg grand theft auto hey
listen man if i didn't have a pc for
grand theft auto 6 i'm building one for
grand theft auto 6 man like that's point
blank period right well i'm gonna keep
it right with you before you get that
super chat
um microsoft would have to put up a
trillion dollars at least we just gonna
be we gonna be real they they gonna have
to do that because rockstar already make
that
the rockstar portion of it makes their
own money as it is like grand theft auto
5 and so how much it could be
i don't know how can you keep talking
i'm gonna look up take two interactives
like how much there were
that's
is that i think that's 2k i saw i saw
when you when you had put that there i
said let me just take a look to see what
they have they have so much
that's that's a trillion dollar purchase
oh god now
it's it's it's around
it looks like i obviously i don't know
how much it would be it would be in the
trillions it would be like yeah
and it's not like i see people in the
chat
like you know talking about you know
well they're not worth the trillion
they're not worth a trillion but the
thing is is
i i i mean i'm looking at it they're
they're definitely not worth a trillion
but the the thing is is you know i guess
it's like just to see people in the chat
say 18 billion so i guess that's
that's what they're worth i don't know
someone should shoot me a leak man 20
billion market cap shoot me a leak on
facebook facebook we don't use facebook
we ain't savages here [ __ ] shoot me a
lick
on twitter someone tweet me
a link
showing how much they're worth because i
couldn't find it i don't know things
like that and i don't know where to look
for things like that but someone in that
chat
shoot me a link show me who who owns
what how much take two interactives work
that's that's borderlands if i'm right
that's 2k whatever all the 2k games
right regardless if we love them i hate
them all the 2k games right
grand theft auto
la noire that's just all the stuff that
come with that hey listen when i say
it's worth a trillion dollars i think
that's what they should charge
to be purchased let me let me let me let
me stake that too
hey look if somebody said they were in
the chat that was worth 18 billion
dollars if that hoes to be true the last
time i checked nintendo themselves was
worth about 16 billion dollars see so i
don't know man i think there's got to be
something up with that because gta well
let me get this super chat real quick so
we got a two dollar subject from brit
bringing him bring him definitely
butchers your name like you know what
man you know how we doing we moving
right past that gta 4's release date
just got bumped up gta 6's release date
uh bro
look bad i don't think they care when
anything's coming that's like a country
no fun speculation there's a lot of
people that there's a lot uh there's
some companies out there that have more
money than countries do easily
they're worth 18 billion i'm gonna need
elites i'm gonna delete guys i ain't
trying to say you're lying
by me late listen again i wanna i just
wanna emphasize the trillion
part was just to say that they don't
they don't need nobody money they don't
need to be acquired i doubt very
seriously that they want to be quiet
like we're going to be real like because
i'm sure microsoft came came to him with
the bag
came to him with the vault it was like
they probably was like now we good
because they sold like having many
copies of grand theft auto they showed
so many copies of grand theft auto at
this point ain't that like like the
guinness book of world records or
something like this it's so far gone
grand i thought it was his own thing you
know it's it's it's own thing at this
point so they nah they don't need that
and they won't do it um
you apparently you search
take
to
market cap
it's 18 billion so they so they do oh no
okay look look
i don't know nothing about the starfire
i'm assuming it's a public company i'm
assuming take two's a public company
so is the market cap the amount of
shares all added up because that's where
i feel like we're going here i feel like
that's the market cap with all their
stocks added up
i don't think that equivalence to ip
ownership and building ownership i think
that's strictly just their stock now am
i correct on this
i know i'm very ignorant when it comes
to anything related to this but to me
when we talk about this 18 billion
dollars i don't think it considers gta i
don't think it considers anything they
own i don't know if they own borderlands
i don't know but to me it doesn't it
doesn't take you into consideration any
of their buildings none of their ips and
what was you going to say also i think i
can i might be able to answer that for
you typically when you see a figure like
that
it's not like net worth it's a lot of
different it's different assets it's
everything together i don't think it's
just the net worth of said company i
could be wrong on that brad bingham with
the two dollar super uh five dollar
super chat nintendo is worth 100 glasses
y'all no nintendo is worth 60 billion
market cap right now assets are worth
about 20 billion use yahoo finance
uh
ttwo i don't know
is the ticker symbol market cap is their
worth okay so oh it's the net worth
let let's let's take
let's give them a little bit let's say
150 bill that's a lot of money it's a
lot of money
and you know that's
you got to consider
that 20 and 60 if this is right
we don't know
it would take more than that for them to
sell why would they sell for just what
their company's worth if microsoft's
reaching out to them they're clearly
going to
latch on to that and they're going to
try to get more do you think bethesda's
worth 7.5 billion dollars hustle
oh no
but if you really want that that company
if you really want that sell what do you
do you you i think they saved the
10-year plan you pay them what they
would make in 10 years on what their
company's worth
so we got another five dollar superchat
from brett man you killing it with these
super chats that i definitely appreciate
man love the support investors will sell
for short-term gains on investments it
is common to get 25 percent more than
their shares are currently worth if they
attempt to buy i agree i understand that
man like it's a lot of money man like
it's a lot of money and you know that's
why i think it is a far-fetched thing
but
it just depends how how much is
microsoft serious about the gaming
industry we've seen they're extremely
serious but are they
are they like 150 billion dollars
serious
that's like 15 bethesda's like
i'm gonna um hey fun speculation shout
out to you um and congrats on 1000 subs
just recently my guy my guy um this is
this is a rumor someone at least the
site that i got from attic was
arrow.com
hey oh oh excuse me a-r-o-g-e-d
and um i think that they heard jez
corden had mentioned that i believe it
was on the last episode of the xbox two
podcasts it was the camera they said it
was on the last episode of the xbox 2
podcast there was no time stamp sadly i
will put that link in the chat but um
this is kind of where we got it from but
um we being railed up
that they ain't about to get no take two
under no circumstances you know how you
said they got to put up 150 billion
dollars they'll make that on their own
anyway
no not only will they make it on their
own it might take them a little longer
but if it's me and i had that that power
if it's me no i'm not giving that up and
let me tell you why because i know i'm
gonna make that and like i said granted
it might take me a little longer to make
that but i know i know if i can make it
on my own then i don't need you i don't
know i don't need your people when it
comes to it those we got you know i see
people want us to move on we'll move on
here in a couple seconds i know a lot of
you are really excited for the
playstation showcase event tomorrow uh
well not tomorrow the day after tomorrow
so
i think
it would be a little bit easier because
if it's a public company you don't have
to deal with like one or two individual
people
you know it and let's be real a lot of
companies there's a handful of people
that own the majority of the shares
so like you really got just got to deal
with them and get majority majority of
the state so i guess like it's easier to
corrupt than people than it is one
person you know what i'm saying like
yeah yeah so i i could see them doing it
no i i could but the question is
is it worth 150 billion dollars like
so i i do get someone down have a good
question i'm going to ask you to hustle
ask you first
do you prefer if they bought take two or
capcom or square oh no or take two or
capcom plus square i saw that i was
gonna correct you too um
for me it'll still be take two for me
for this very reason
why i like capcom stuff
um the people who i want to have work on
marvel vs capcom too that's digital
eclipse and i don't really like had like
the history that like say like a bg or
yourself may have like read the resident
evil series and stuff like that that's
that's y'all thing for real i know cap
comics monster hunter capcom they they
have a lot of franchises square i'm not
really a fan of what they do in
particular i'm not a final fantasy cat i
just what they work on the only thing
that i love from them personally is
super mario rpg and i was over 25 years
ago and then they won't do they won't
give us another one of those what's up
with that man nope
nope
they don't care about us but um
no no if for me it's take two because
then we gotta realize the franchises
that we or the games that we didn't
mention state of emergency love it i
hate it people people we'll go back to
that
give you one second big salsa or however
you want me to pronounce your name
look if you think pew if you think take
two is worth 150 billion you're on drugs
we're not saying it's worth 150 billion
we're saying that when it comes to
buying a company for what they're worth
you're going to want to add on a
significant amount of money if you want
to make sure that you get that point
across for instance we were saying that
you would probably have to double the
amount of st the the cost in the stocks
that alone is going to raise the the the
price significantly and then not to
mention if you if there are a handful
people that own the majority of the
stocks they're not going to sit you
might get one
and then once these people start talking
to each other and they find out what
you're doing then
is that technically a hostile takeover
like that's what you're slowly starting
to do i don't know nothing about this so
to me it's going to take a significant
amount of money to get to to handle this
kind of situation continue what you were
saying yeah i said earlier i said a
trillion dollars earlier but hey you
know i'm just i'm just crazy old hustle
over here um shout out to uh dallas man
the voice one of the voices over there
at
levelonegaming.com
uh he says capcom plus square is beyond
legendary now i know that's that's my
boy right there he he's into them rpgs
that's
that's what he do listen i like capcom
for like the music and the different
things that they've produced like mega
man like i love the music and mega man i
ain't really good at the game like that
don't kill me don't kill me but um they
have a lot of marquee or mark franchises
i think it's dope but uh not i just take
two all day for me to answer that
question this take two seven days a week
for me too and if for real it's based on
grand theft auto although yeah like i'm
not gonna lie like they can bring back
midnight club there's so many different
possibilities that they could do with
that yeah and not to mention you know
someone said uh you only have to pay
like 20 30 about premium
i think
to me
this is this isn't your average buyout
like this is this is take too
interactive like
i just feel like
it's gonna be more than 20 or 30 billion
dollars like i feel like if you went to
them and you showed
i got you 50 billion dollars they're
gonna laugh you out of the room because
that's not that's not even double what
their company's worth
and it's like someone said earlier that
market cap is just the shares for what
people in the chat say so why would they
sell for just what their shares are
worth when they're getting pretty much
almost identical to that and what the
properties they own around the world but
we're going to move on with that because
we don't know a whole lot about that i'm
just giving
i'm just giving a
you know the outside the ignorant
outside person looking in i don't know
anything about that it's just how i
would assume something like that will go
over but i don't know how that goes over
so i'll be going on there saying addicts
spreading misinformation i mean you can
if you want i just won't listen to you
got a mute button on twitter for a
reason but you know
let's let's move on to the playstation
showcase prediction show we've got to
talk about this playstation stuff man
uh let me
okay so let me get this five dollar
super chat from brit
okay so how do you pronounce this man's
name because i always butcher it
oh wait oh
hold on hold on
it says
whoa
my man name is lord stark killing no not
the one above that uh what's the ceo's
name again
of microsoft satia like i always butcher
his name
satya
satya nadella yes take a look at simpson
nick's twitter feed and reply xbox
replied to jazz gordon about the meme
they posted earlier look i'm not saying
it's not even possible
wait a minute
i'm just telling you that this is this
is a crazy purchase and we said earlier
if they bought them the world is indeed
on twitter i'm gonna have to i'ma have
to go to some of these big big
playstation fan boys and i'm gonna have
to get uh what's that thing where you
you check on people um
what was my wife alert what's your name
flirt what's the thing when you check on
people you have the cops go up to them
and make sure they're okay
um
sir i'm thinking about squatting people
but i know that no
what is the term when you have someone
check on someone i wrote this check
wellness check that's what it is okay
i'm gonna have to get some wellness
checks upon some of these people man i
might have to check on the man because
i'm gonna be very very concerned with
some of these people imagine if gta gta
6 was just poof off the playstation
can you imagine like that's like listen
if you thought the bethesda deal or the
xenomax deal was a big deal i think
twitter would break that day i think
that would be something that would
literally break the internet that would
actually make like they would definitely
make national like yeah oh my god that
would be one of those things where i
would be slowly starting like
bethesda i didn't think was a big deal
because of the way bethesda fights you
features like
i felt like it was a good fit now right
the inner fanboy in me
that just loves to see things burn
wants it to happen because i want to
take off a day and i'm tell you guys
right now if take two was brought by
microsoft first thing i'm doing is
calling my boss to say i'm sick can't go
to work
and then i'm gonna i'm gonna get in my
bed i'm gonna get my tablet because it's
not even worth my phone i got a seat in
big screens man and i'ma just i'm gonna
just absorb all of all of the twitter
i'm gonna just absorb it
breathe it out
breathe it out oh my goodness
yeah it's just jokes
let me get it we're getting back behind
on these super chats a little bit we got
a ten dollar super from lord star killer
x3 zx01
sony's net worth is 132 billion
microsoft is a two plus trillion dollar
company slam dunk purchase take two
currently worth 18.7 billion great show
i appreciate the uh
the kind words sir i appreciate the kind
words we got to find out from jared mack
leftover from microsoft's market cap
could easily buy take two hashtag the
change
that's funny man
i gotta do that for you man i like that
so much hold on let me find the the
hashtag the change
there you go there you go then we got a
ten dollar super channel i like this man
cave forever uh shout out to him with
the destiny uh the destiny references
have you seen the former cd projekt red
creative director 12 year veteran not
butchering his name is available looking
for work ps on twitter he loves pills of
eternity weak wink
so he he's definitely uh you know he's
hinting some stuff man he's ending some
stuff it'd be cool if we get some you
know good talent over there at microsoft
and uh he likes pillar of eternity i'm
pretty sure they're making another one
um oh okay so he's the creative director
now we know what what awful dumpster
fire cyberpunk 2077 was i still got that
game on pc by the way i never gave it
back i'm three hours and i never gave a
dream back um
well he's the creative director i think
that he will be a great fit
well anyway he'll be great for any way
he goes because like i kind of like i
like the world of cyberpunk i even like
how you can go through like the
different things and i've seen a few of
the different endings like the character
development so if he's the creative
director that
you know that that's that's a pickup
that's a good pick up for damning
anybody in the industry i'm gonna be
right because it wasn't his fault that
game came out like that
i think for the most part if you ask any
of those devs that worked at cd projekt
red they all would say we would prefer
to move the project like but at the end
of the day
i only think cd projekt reds are bad
developers i don't even think you know
it's the core studio now the executives
and the people that want that money you
could have a debate on them and at the
end of the day can you even have a
debate on them because they're being
pressured by investors yeah so it's just
like the game was being a development
too long and throughout the lighter it
just got pushed out and i get it we're
not going to get too much into that
we're going to go back to this
playstation show okay so let's let's
break this down first off see what's
funny
is i don't even know too many of
sony
uh playstation
playstation studios
i wonder if there's like a website that
i could see them all like a list of them
man
i did it earlier um
i did it earlier it's kind of out of
date because when i was when i did
looked up
stuff i was looking up stuff for the uh
that playstation
was that the playstation multiplayer
game
get this gamepl you guys can feel free
to go to it too if you guys want to if
you're on computers i know it's a little
bit harder if you're on a phone
fun speculation that that'll definitely
be there um the gran turismo thing i
actually i actually got that written
down as a matter of fact like i would be
surprised if it wasn't there because
that was one of the first games that we
saw during the uh the very first
showcase the future gaming showcase that
they did for um i think was back in june
of right before the console came out
this is right before we saw everything
so i i do i definitely expect that to be
there if not man something somebody got
some explaining to do that's all got
some explaining to do yeah that was one
of the first joints they showed man i'm
just saying
you know if you think about this like i
know
hold up let me let me f11 this again
uh no i have to left with the wrong
screen let me have 11 this
so let me go
i just realized this xbox first
party stream
xbox first party
um
i'll read some of the chat while we're
getting that together afropunk shout out
to you he said he is hoping for a socom
reboot
i don't know if you'll get there brother
um i'm keeping right with you i think i
think the socon is uh
i want to say dead and gone i think so
clown is uh long gone
right so
i don't think that this doesn't
incorporate bethesda this is just like
the core studios right now it is kind of
crazy
like the difference in studios that
microsoft and sony have
like
oh yeah that
it looked wild on paper right
and we didn't
even bethesda
like they own more than that yes studios
but that's the game studios
let's go man let's go i know i'm being
messy right now but it's okay it's okay
because it's the attic show i could be
messy
you know we we didn't have an iop last
sunday
uh because you know uh we we we're about
to go to the to the whack you know the
whack 11 a.m oh yeah but by the way this
this week where it's going to be 11 a.m
uh and i don't know
i'm pretty sure you guys won't be able
to see this yeah you can't see this okay
i'm bringing up the schedule oh my god
if if i if i brought up the schedule on
a stream cognito would have my face
why did you do that because we tried to
surprise you guys man and if i
accidentally you know snitch on our
whole schedule like all two months of it
people would get he would get a little
bit upset with me okay so i i'm not
gonna go too too much into when it comes
to um
that but you know it is pretty
significant
the amount of people
i don't know why what the age of impact
it's fine we're going to stop being
messy or start actually doing things
the difference in studios is just crazy
it really is like so let's let's go into
this the first one is team uh astro so
i'm assuming this is the people that
make uh astro ball correct um t team
with sophie yeah it's sophie okay my bad
my bad looking fine so
team of soapy are they there
if we're talking about the future of
playstation
yes
astro by if you guys were you on the ps5
addict did you play in beat astrobot
that was good i actually really enjoyed
that game that
listen there's only one bad part of that
game and that's the gpu where you you're
the monkey and you got to climb up the
thing i hated that part outside of that
that that joint was fire boy like
yeah that that's how you that's the tech
demo into a game like that's something i
really enjoy
not only are they there but i think we
get a sneak peek a brief one i think we
get a sneak peek of
the next adventure for astro bob because
astro bot as you all know it's
that's their new sac boy that's their
new crash bandicoot that is their new
little cute little mascot that you can
sell to the kids and i don't think that
takes a long time to to make either like
if you think about it those type of
experiences you could probably push one
out in two years like like i don't think
they take extremely long unless they
like unless they have something bigger
than they had with astrobot i was gonna
say no i think that this one will be a
more this one's gonna be a full-fledged
game i actually would just say a
prediction i would i would i don't want
them doing that like if you want my
opinion i want them to take astro bot
and just make that you because you know
astrobot was kind of a game that kind of
expanded on their other ips it was like
kind of like a like a mascot joke
like let you go into you know areas
where uh you you saw like the ps1 stuff
you saw the ps2 stuff i want them to do
that on a different scale like you know
kind of like kingdom hearts
but the worlds or worlds of their actual
first party studio you know what i'm
saying like
that would be cool yeah i just want to
say oh yeah well astro astro's playroom
definitely was a love letter to the
history of playstation i think that's
why i enjoyed it so much because there
was a lot that i knew about ps3 that i
didn't know i mean that i didn't know
about ps2 for real for real and um there
were things that i saw with the ps1 um
there's a lot they had like all the
handhelds had the psp they had to beat
it like it would be dope like if they
did have their own separate worlds and
that would that actually will be though
um
i'm there but but you know what though
if they do that if they take this idea
and expand the pound it expand a pound
it you know what never mind words are
hard but if they do that and then they
they really maximize and flesh out this
idea then that will probably be the
ultimate like love letter of the
playstation that will be the ultimate
history of and that that would be
something i look forward to personally
seriously in all seriousness i look
forward to that all right so let let's
move on and i think so i think astro
ball is a good title where they can
consistently get it out there pretty
good and it's quality because you know i
don't think it takes a whole lot to make
those type of games and they can they
can make good quality games but this
next one
rocky game the last one
people who made days gone ben studio
hustle are they there
hmm
yes
yes
i say it i say it reluctantly because we
know what happened with days gone we
know it didn't sell as well but what we
also heard
was that they were going to work on
something else
they're not going to work on days gone
from what i understand from that david
jaffee interview that the gentleman did
so they probably won't work on that uh
maybe i'm getting confused with the
stuff that i saw on twitter and stuff
that i saw online they're not gonna work
on that and they all working on
something new so this roman that they're
working on something new if this is
playstations e3 we know how playstation
get down
and i don't mean this in a slanderous
way but place they'll show a game that's
four years out
they will definitely show a game they
would they will
i feel
i feel like maybe they'll try to stay
away from that because they got a lot of
slander last gen for it uh especially
like towards the end of the generation
where there was games like last of us
that was shown at the beginning of the
generation still not out
like
i'm be honest with you i think they
might stay to the two to three years not
like the five to six years you know what
i'm saying like i feel that but i don't
i mean i'm gonna be real with you i
don't think it matters
i mean for for me personally it doesn't
like that type of thing oh this is cool
like when i saw the last of us two for
the first time it's like uh not jack
trenton
sean layton came out hey this is
playstation experience this game is
early in development game look good to
me so that's last of us too
some things are well worth the wait um i
give playstation at that leeway because
it really i'm basing off the uncharted
series like i'm having you know i'm
streaming i'm having a great time with
that like i'm giving them that based off
of the impact that uncharted has set on
me but
i digress and you know i don't want to
take up too much of the time i fought my
fault
man so i i did put a poll in the chat
you know um
you can definitely go and do that for a
little bit
real quick look at these haters oh man
you hate to see it
so you go ahead and fill out the uh you
know do that vote man do you think ben's
studio is going to be there man do you
think ben's studio is going to be there
so it does look like uh it's uh 25.75
right now so 75 percent of people think
you're full of [ __ ] hustle
25
25 of people don't think they think
they'll be there
so
i mean
i think it's possible i i do understand
where house was coming from and
especially to me
i feel like
it would be cheaper for them to make
another days gone than would be for them
to make a new ip unless the new ip isn't
going to be
um
it isn't going to have the kind of
funding that day's gone you know what
i'm saying
uh because to me it feels like it's
cheaper to to build on to a game and on
to a universe that you've already took
the time to create
not necessarily engine wise but it'd be
easier to recreate that world and
another engine that would be to make
another world from scratch you know what
i'm saying
yeah and i'll say this before we move on
if it doesn't work was sony ben was it
sony ben who was going to be
absorbed into a naughty dog north was
that the studio or am i thinking of
something else because it was two
situations that went on with the people
who tried to remake the last of us i
know a lot of those people left the last
of us part one that remake is coming and
that that's actually in my predictions
by the way
um
yeah yeah no i got that there for sure
but it was i forget what studio was it
might have been the lesser it might have
been like a independent studio that kind
of just helps
other larger studios like finish up
their projects i know that they were
trying to remake last of us part one
and i think that they were trying to i
think jim ryan or
tried to rebrand him into naughty dog
north i might be wrong with that don't
don't quote me on that i do remember
what you're saying i think jason
schreier covered it didn't he yes he did
i'm just getting i'm just getting the
wires crossed so forgive me for that
just forgive me for that
oh you're fine man you're only been
there i see that i like that phone
no i just i see the results at the
bottom that's all
i thank you for voting
okay so next one
to be there so next one's going to be
guerrilla games so i'll put the poll in
the chat too because we're going to go
over what the chat things after we talk
so
hustles girl are going to be there they
they horizon forbidden west i think
that's the name um you know
i feel like
there's no way they'll be there but they
could be working on another title
so
uh they're the people who made infamous
are they not
um i don't think so i think they may
kill zone
i can't make so i'll get that right
who made infamous
it might be saint monica i think the
people
no they didn't know sucker punched i
believe
yes yes yes now i remember now remember
so
yes they made um they made a kill zone
and yeah the people make ghost research
the the ones that made ghost yoshishima
made uh infamous so
all right so now we're we've moved past
my uh my
my someone said insomniac
so gorilla
do you think they're there
clearly you know uh stuff's going on
with them
uh what what do you think they show
uh horizon forbidden west you think
they're gonna reshow horizon forbidden
west all right i gotta sit up
i i think no no i got an issue if they
show for ben west i think i think they
do show it i think they show a little
bit of gameplay and but they don't show
that much of it i think they're gonna
have their own dedicated thing around
i would like to say december for their
own dedicated state of play well maybe
maybe even january right i think they
have their own thing in january to be
like hey you know thank you all for
waiting they apologize so on and so
forth but i definitely think gorilla is
there if we're talking about
what's the name of this the future
playstation what's the name of the
showcase yeah it's called the
playstation showcase 2021 i should
probably change this
which is fine if this is their version
of e3 i definitely think we see that i
think we just see i think we see a
little bit of
they wouldn't want to gameplay it they
showed this gameplay before i think they
show us a little bit more they probably
go a little bit more in depth in terms
of the combat system i think they think
they may explain that a little more if
they do carry on because this show is
only 40 minutes
so i but i definitely do think that
they're going to be there that's one of
their heavy hitters
i would be surprised if they weren't
there
i'm going to be real with you hustle if
horizon's there it's an l
is it is it right because the game's
coming out in february yeah that we've
seen plenty of gameplay on horizon we
got the release date we've seen we've
seen a lot on horizon do not waste any
of this 40 minutes on this damn game
no wasting chat put a one if you agree
with me put it two if you agree with
hustle we need some chat interaction so
i can prove dawn so that he wrong so put
a one if you agree with me and the two
of you agree of hustle
i i think um wow all right i see well i
feel one in the chat yeah to put the
exclamation point behind that
i
appreciate y'all
now let me leave me out here that but no
but i i literally think that they'll
show even if it's quick i definitely
think that because it's an upcoming
title so it wouldn't surprise me if they
just they they show a little bit and
they said hey you know
oh my god
first of all i'd probably be into that
but no i think they show a little
something and then they cut it short
like hey if you guys want to see this
they promote the next thing that they'll
be on for their own game
it go i encourage you to go back i don't
know if you've watched our uh the last
little thing that xbox did when the the
gamescom thing you'll see me be
disgusted when they show forza horizon
again like i i don't want them to no
it's just anyone i don't like when
people keep showing the same game over
and over again
and i think that's one of the biggest
issues playstation has is because they
they announce all these games so soon
and then they they keep showing them
over and over again until they come out
and it's just like look like you know at
the end of the day
i do understand where you're coming from
it's one of their biggest games but to
me we've seen it multiple times let's
move on like
let's show something else i don't care
if they have to do like
a like a logo of their next game at that
point like it's just like i'd rather see
a logo of a game that i can't touch for
five years to see a game that i'm going
to touch next month that i've seen not
next year that i've seen
damn near every other month this year
you know what i'm saying like
you talk about logos for um certain
games when we get to a certain studio my
favorite playstation studio
if you say monica
sir sorry you're going to say something
no or you can say song yeah no naughty
dog naughty dog oh you have a
yeah yeah all right so that's part one
hey look number two uncharted 2.
it's going to be interesting man because
we're going to disagree on some of this
stuff i already know it man all right i
already know it so here's what the chat
had to say will gorilla
going to be there
uh 75 said yes and 25 said no it's kind
of crazy how this is changing i think
the last one was 75 and 25 percent yeah
so the last time around yeah
and you know i i don't i don't think
they're gonna be there i really don't i
think that
for me personally they'd be stupid to
show horizon i'm not horizon yeah
horizon it's it's awfully funny that
horizons both horizons are being shown
too much
so okay so let's
house marquee
obviously
they just showed this game the game just
released which is maternal which
look there's a lot of issues going at
launch with fraternal but i actually
thought it was a good game and i thought
it was better than ratchet and clank
that's just me
i really really enjoyed return on i
still ain't beat maternal and i think
maybe it's because like
when i die after doing two hours of
fraternal
i'm just mentally done i'm like i'm out
like you know what i'm saying but
hustle
is how's marky gonna be there
yes
oh and you're reaching for the stars
i think yeah oh no i think i think
playstation gonna pull up for real for
real and not only do i think um
house mark will be there
they
well they want to announce the
acquisition because they don't need to
do that but i think that they'll have
dlc
for return
also also i think they'll implement some
type of save system now that's just me
wishing for the stars i think they
actually because
we remember how that game came out in
the type of condition that came out in
you had to have your console in rest
mode in order to like really keep going
and the reason why i didn't want to put
my console on rest mode it was because
it's a day one console we didn't know if
all above is my own though i am on my
console brick so on and so forth i was a
little paranoid but i did play return on
when i did enjoy it um i'm not good at
it but i definitely enjoyed it i think
that
i think the audience may have heard the
outcry
uh from certain creators but just in
general hey this isn't working hey i'm
losing all this progress so on and so
forth so if they don't put a save point
after every biome what they'll do is
they'll put a save point probably second
uh six biomes i do believe so it's two
four and six so they'll probably do it
the second fourth and sixth one the
fourth one anyway i think that they
could have easily fit
a safe system in the game that made
sense that you had to pay ether to save
that's a good idea actually yeah
you you go in
and not it's not one of those things
where you have to pay cert like if you
save this is such a like a away from our
model we're not going to ask for one or
two ether we want all of them suckers
and if you really want to save
you don't have to give us all the ether
you got
and i think that would be a really good
like middle ground i know a lot of
people have issues and they like to like
have a it's some of these people bg
want to have like like a a difficult
game
like like they want to be the the
barrier police oh you can't come in here
you can't come in here oh shaco can't
get difficulties you can't come in here
get good get good
i've just always been one of those
people i don't care how people play
games i really don't and and to me there
is a condition here the base games got
to be still intact and they got to
downgrade it to make that easier mode
ah yeah i mean i'll say this in closing
as far as this goes i think it would be
dope if um if they did have some type of
save system if they put attach the
parasite to you right that that would
inflict
something they'll it either take
something away from you or inflict some
type of damage on you until you can get
that parasite off you once every time
that you save the game i think that
that'd been like though but i mean maybe
that's maybe that's a little too
ambitious like for me but i think
something like that would have been cool
but you know me man hey if the game is
hard and i just can't beat it i just
can't finish it it's all good but i
still want that company or i want that
studio to have their integrity like that
that integrity that's their vision right
if i did youtube when somebody tried to
change my vision of what i'm doing on
youtube i'll be very upset just as a
creative i would be upset that's why i
never had a i don't have a problem with
the difficulty um in second row i'm
gonna problem difficulty and paternal if
i'm just not good or demon souls too if
i'm not good at it i just gotta play it
enough to get good at it and yeah y'all
all these games ain't hard you can get
over it well you can overcome it it's
cool i saw somebody real quick before we
move on i saw somebody play street
fighter 5 competitively
and he had like a nub falling off and he
was playing with his mouth i i swear to
god right hand and god
somehow things can be done
i seen some dude that's really good at
apex legends that has no arms like yep
things can be done like like when you
see people overcome
you know difficult stuff like that you
just like
we need to stop [ __ ]
these people you know they have legit
you know conditions where they shouldn't
they
you know they they had to break a mental
barrier and even play games
and you know they they didn't ask for
you know difficulties be pushed back
they just
they got past those mental barriers and
you got like that's just crazy like to
to think you know someone is playing
apex legends better with no arms than i
am playing with arms like
it's it's crazy man so let's go ahead
and
let's go to the next one man and i know
you know what the next one is man right
oh hold up let me go ahead and in this
poll so uh with the po and the people
have spoken well you guys see what i
just did there didn't you see what i did
there
and it does look like um man is it ever
going to pop up
there it goes so it looks like house
marquis going to be there
75 said no 25 said yes it's crazy we
keep getting these 75 25.
all right
so
insomniac games
all right
what what what do you uh what what is
your opinion on insomniac games
first and foremost spider-man 2.
do you think they're going to be there
i think that they are going to be there
like again if we talk about do you
expect every studio to be here also i
don't expect media molecule to be there
but we're not there yet
we're not there yet
no no i expect the top tier studios to
be there maybe and maybe um
house mark isn't specifically maybe top
tier but i'm not going to go ahead on
but my point is i do expect for them to
be there because
that turnaround with spider-man and then
the spider-man miles morales it was a
quick little turnaround insomniac they
are the coalition
studios for playstation so i definitely
expect for them to be there um do i
expect to see anything in regards to
spider-man 2 in terms of gameplay no but
i figured we'd get a trailer or
something i figured maybe we get some
quick narration that peter may be
talking i faced my greatest challenge
ever so on and so forth and yeah you
know if you know what happens at the end
of the miles morales you know what i'm
talking about so i'm gonna try i'm not
trying to do it fc violet said someone
tell this man this is only 45 minute
show hey hey hey fc you better let me
dream i know it's a 45 minute show sir
we got that that poll in there man uh in
so many games are they going to be there
here's my thing are there i see people
in the chat do say that think ratchet
and clank uh some kind of dlc is going
to be there
i doubt it because if you look at it
from you know the previous one i don't
think they had any dlc for the original
ratchet and 2016 did they i don't think
so
i don't know i'm at the end of the day
might i don't think that this dlc with
it
might be different but
personally to me i feel like they're not
going to do that i feel like insomniac's
done enough they've literally carried
the ps5 up to this point on their backs
so i don't think i think it's fine that
they go sit in their little corner and
play their legos and make their next
game i don't think no one's going to say
anything if they're not there
oh yeah i mean and you know if one
studio does get a pass for it it's
definitely inside me like they
oh
i think it's like equivalent to
when we had the e3 show last
i've not really seen any huge presence
of of coalition like they're like
coalition literally carried the xbox one
generation on their back like like go
sit in your
your corner
and i only want to say legos man you're
building blocks
and make your next game man like don't
don't waste time coming to this and
making events making any kind of you
know thing to show at this type of event
like just work on your game so i i i
think you know uh it does look like
uh you know let's let's go to the poll
questions talk a little bit about what
the chat's saying man okay insomniac
games going to be there 70 said yes
and 30 said no so they agree with you
hustle
they agree with you and they disagree
with me and all that really means to
them is you got 30 of the people in the
chat that's right 70 of the chat that's
wrong all right y'all so when we see
insomniac there no i i got a feeling we
will definitely see them there and i
think it will be spider-man 2 related i
don't think it's going to be ratchet and
clank related they probably excuse me
they may go over those numbers hey we i
think they sold a million in like a
month or something like that they might
go over those numbers but hey this is
what we did but this is what we're
working on like we know why you're here
we know why you're really here and we
put in the flex on i think they do that
so
all right hustle yep there's random
studios that no one knows what they do
what the hell is london studio what do
they make
i don't know i saw listen when i saw
london studio
games i don't think i look in the chat
cause i'm looking right now it looks
like i see blood and truth
uh playstation vr world y'all this is vr
so they have vr studio yeah i'm looking
at um
nope they won't be there because the
playstation uh
somebody had came out from playstation
was like hey we're not covering vr
good they won't be there yep
we don't need to see the studio ever to
be honest with you like
i could go my whole life without seeing
any more vr stuff oh man okay so uh
media molecule
hold on hold on hold on hold on y'all
mods
let's let's let's
let's get him up out of there
he did that in jacksonville chat
yesterday same never mind the same one
they could they could be there uh just
we won't address them from now on just
uh mods get them up out here if they pop
in again okay so media molecule
i'm gonna say they gonna be there
they're gonna be there i'm saying they
couldn't be there wait attic you might
be onto something
let's uh quote you might be onto
something here's where i'm going with it
though
we just recently heard that uh nexus was
acquired by playstation to make pc ports
for all of these games right we heard
this a little while ago i'm i for one am
happy about it this leads me into my
next thing i ain't even talking about
media molecule this leads me to my next
thing the uncharted franchise is rumored
to be coming to the pc from my charter
one two three four
five well lost legacy pardon me four and
lost legacy right
it's all room to be there
look i know i know i'm there wrong with
this don't put no pulling in the chat
but
there's already paul in the chat oh
jesus i i think
i think no no i mean don't put no paul
in the chat what i'm about to say i
think that the entire uncharted series
will be available on pc not right away
but i think they do what a staggered
release like uh like a massive chief
collection
yep i think i think they do i think they
do what they did there and they i don't
think they can have to do that i'm gonna
ask the chat put a one and put a two if
you disagree
i feel like if they announce pc stuff at
this it's an l
yeah like it's just a straight l and not
only is it l it's like a dragon fist
from from dragon ball l like it like if
they announce some pc
i don't want to see steam on the on the
screen
i don't want to see epic games
actually i probably would be okay with
seeing epic game store i love seeing
people [ __ ] about the epic game store
but
l
if they show pc stuff at a playstation
experience showcase
the place that it's literally called
playstation showcase 2021 hustle why
would i want to see pc stuff at this
event we're talking about ports
we're talking about ports in my island
now with symbols voice ports
we talking about ports this is what we
talking about not the new games
that's the new games we talking about
ports it's cool man and they probably
won't show it that's just me just that's
my pie in the sky for the day but i had
to reach out and get that one but they
probably won't but it'll be dope if they
did look hey look i love playing
uncharted you know at 60 frames but i
would love to play in charlotte even
more at 120 so on and so forth look this
is hot rock that's how i rock but yeah
they probably won't but i hope they do
they um i got that information from an
alleged leak from a reset era i'm not
sure how reliable reset there is and i'm
not going to take a dump on them i'm
just saying there's something floating
around it looked like a terrible
photoshop job of the uncharted
collection
it looked bad it looked like something i
did it looked like one of my thumbnails
it looked super bad it looked bad but um
you know people are running with that
idea people are making news articles
about that that's why i brought it up uh
no but to answer your original question
media molecule will not be there
why i'm i'm on busy
time with it dog i'm just not going to
go
that's no that's something that needs to
go to pc anything that media molecule
makes like the last little thing that
they made with the how you can create a
game and all that that that should have
been on pc that's that's not even the
thing should have been day and day that
would've helped that game uh you know
tremendously but
that ain't gonna be there
and i don't care for real
so
sorry y'all
all right so um
need a michael
we're gonna say naughty dog saint monica
and sucker punch for last so
what is the hell is this what are the oh
these people make the mlb the show
um say uh san diego studio san diego yes
yeah so um
real quick we'll wrap up that last poll
it does look like uh
67 people said no media molecule is not
going to be there and 32 percent of
people said that
uh they would be there so you know my 32
people get double the votes
so
do you think that
i think it's safe to say that this this
the show is not going to be in any way
shape or form unless they you know
somehow got their hands on like the nfl
license or something like that like
i doubt they would even if nlb was about
to come out and this was like the time
they would announce the next one i don't
think they would show mob like a yearly
installment on this stage
i think um i think they highlight the
numbers because apparently it's sold the
most that it's ever sold period so that
would be a dope thing to see like
they're not gonna show those sales
numbers so don't you play hey
congratulations to sony san diego we
look forward to making more stuff in the
future real quick
um it will be dope if sony san diego
um or pardon me in san diego studio went
the same route that um
turned 10
went um shout out to sir dre um over
there with um kidsmove with the ltd
podcast he had the twitter spaces
earlier he got into a little
little disagreement on twitter and he
pretty much was like yo why can't this
other company make a new thing so when i
see turn 10 making fable and fable looks
good by the way i remember i remember
kicking it with y'all and watching that
the whole e3 thing fable looks really
good so there's not a doubt in my mind
that you know people from sony san diego
it's not it's not a doubt in my mind
that they could do something else and if
i'm playstation to be completely honest
with you i wouldn't even bother with
i mean i look if mlb continues to sell
cool but the second they dip
you have to make something else all
right that's it and that's how i feel
all right so
let's go
we don't really got to go too much into
that you know 84 said no i think we all
agree and we'll be wack so why would
they be here all right so uh
pixel
what what did they do what does pixel do
i don't know what they do
concrete genie they make concrete oh
okay let's just let's just blow through
this because obviously the top threes
the ones we want to talk about is pixel
gonna be here
uh
i think yes they can easily be okay i
don't think so they're any studio they
could definitely make something
worthwhile
i mean i feel that but no i mean if you
ask me in a 40-minute show i i don't
think that they're around this i think
they'll have their own little state of
play for that
but but you think they could show
horizon forbidden west again in that one
one thousand percent you saw about the
eye people i mean a mark a marquis
you know you talk about one of their top
10 franchises yes one thousand percent i
doubt that was that
all right so
we're gonna skip the rest of the grand
trizmo they're gonna be there because i
don't wanna make this yeah i don't wanna
make this too too long so we're gonna
yeah uh collaboration with external
studios we're going to talk about that
we're gonna talk about that in terms of
a third party here in a couple of
minutes uh but let's go ahead and get
we're talking about sucker punch first
let's talk about soccer punch
um do you think sucker punches here
i don't think so if if they are there
it'll be a brief mention about ghost to
sushima um the expansion that just came
out it'll be a brief
quick little thing about hey we
appreciate you guys for working for
buying uh expansion
dude we glad that you're having fun is
it ikea island i believe yes uh you guys
are having fun at iggy island take gin
on some more missions someone you know
pr talk so on and so forth
i if they are there and i don't think
they will be but if they are there they
probably talk about you know the quick
like success of upset game
so you want you you think it's possible
that they go on there and gloat about
how well go sushi
we love to show you guys the analytics
and they just go
here is how it's sold
let me correct myself maybe that's not
what i mean i i just i think that they
just do like a quick thank you like hey
you know thank you for playing our game
you know
it's a new ip i think that i think i
think it's just like a quick thank you
um just and probably just promotion for
ikea or for the ikea island lp lp
expansion pardon me i think it's just a
quick little
little thing hey we got this thing i'll
play our game and that's it
i think
there's a good chance they're not going
to be i'd say like 70 chance they're not
going to be here
30 maybe announcing like a new like ray
type of thing that's in the legends
thing i i don't know if they were going
to do another one
but i am kind of curious if you know
that's going to be there uh not to
mention uh there's a huge rumor going
around that infamous is getting remade
or some form of infamous project right
regardless if it's a remake or a sequel
so if it would be there maybe they're
doing that they have a second team um
maybe another studio entirely is making
it and we just don't know yet
so
i'm kind of curious how it's going to go
yeah
shout out to
stodgy caesar in the chat he said
they're not coming up to say thank you
you might be right bro i mean dog you
might be right you might be right i'm
not gonna lie i don't know it was just
that is just funny though
thank you for helping us sell
bye
this is three minutes of this 40 minute
show
they're gonna have the flute man come
out and do it he's gonna like know the
direction
oh no i don't know so now so we probably
won't see that morning like we probably
won't all right so it looks like the
chat i asked the chat is sucker punch
going to be there
51 said yes and 49
said no
no it just changed
49 said yes and 51 percent said i don't
know if you just said that yeah you're
like
it's always changing oh it's still
changing okay it's like it's like
everyone decided to vote like at the
very last minute
i i think it's a 50 50 to be honest with
you i do think it's like a 50 50. i'm
not going to bring the the screen up
anymore guys because uh we know what the
last studios are
yeah all right so
i want to say
i don't know what should we do first
saint monica or naughty dog i feel like
these are their two best studios
let's go over my favorite studio naughty
dog let's do it first okay let's do
naughty dog first
is
naughty dog going to be at this event
one thousand percent guess one thousand
percent one to one one thousand percent
and i'll actually go into details i took
some notes oh you took notes oh yeah
let's get it let's get it let's see we
see the the last of us part one we see
that remake that that remake that was
going on with the studio and having
noted we see that you definitely see
that
we see a factions two release date if we
don't see any gameplay we definitely see
a faction's two release date oh we still
have hope that factions two is a real
thing
oh yeah one thousand okay okay there's
there's still actually i love like your
your your percentages man 1 000 that's
right
i mean i know that i know that they're
still hiring for the multiplayer so we
probably won't see it like i said we get
a release date i didn't say when the
release date was but we i feel like we
get a release we're made out of release
date but we do get a release window for
factions too so one thousand percent
i i think we do and then
it's a little caveat if we don't see or
we don't see or hear anything about it
there they're doing outbreak day then
that's one thousand percent yeah
i would be
it would be i love how you're completely
ignoring it
listen that would be a l if they didn't
say nothing on um on outbreak day that'd
be a l
then um let's see what else whatever
theories i got uh let's see
man you really went above and beyond for
this this naughty dog did i did um right
now we don't know who's working on
uncharted 5 because i heard it was
naughty dog but then i heard it wasn't
but then i heard it was again if we do
if we do
see um
anything new from
naughty dog it'll be that um
i'll just call it endurance survive
which is the name of i think the name of
the comic in the last of us one that
roma to be working on the game and outer
space
i think maybe we don't see nothing from
it but i think we get like a little
splash screen like hey we're working on
this thing we get the metroid prime
effect like
they got the music and the stuff we're
not start filled because starfield kind
of went in today there was a trailer it
was a dope little trailer but i think
it's a quick little splash screen if the
game the name of the game would probably
be endurance survive it would make more
sense if it was so we see that rumored
new naughty dog ip
i i think we see that um
it's a toss-up between uncharted 5 right
because we don't i wouldn't want nothing
though to be um
creatively like held back
but however however look if you are
going to finish off uncharted 5
at least with naughty dog you give them
their their last game you make it with
sam chloe and nadine
you don't you don't pick up with nate's
daughter because she ain't old enough
yet but you pick up with those three i
think if you
i think if there is a sequel it's going
to be
enough time goes by
or his daughter is
is old enough i i don't i think they did
that whole thing at the end of uncharted
4 to build up with
a possibility not necessarily
do they want to make it uncharted 5 but
if they did they have somewhere to go
with it and i think the people you're
talking about
um i think there's multiple scenarios
one of them might become evil
yeah it's hard to tell what happens
there um
they they might take the you know the
nurturing approach where they're helping
her
uh
i think it's more i think it's more that
yeah or they split them and one half of
them becomes evil and the other one
doesn't like
i
i kind of considering how the lost
legacy ended i don't think i think that
they would
they would bring her up
they would bring um nathan's daughter up
i don't know her name because i haven't
played in b-paw four year but i don't
know her name but they're gonna bring
her up and then and put her wrong game
so to speak they're gonna they're gonna
bring her into that world and i think
it's gonna be against nathan's and
elena's wishes but i think she still
gets in there i think she get that she
get that bug she get that rush
and i think you know sam sam is going to
be like the key fact of come on i got
you
wake up
yeah yep i think sam is going to be the
determining factor for that but all
right either way yep by the way so the
chat says
first off let me say what i'm saying i
think they're going to be there um
i think it's just going to be
a factions announcement attached to a
remaster of uncharted one or the last of
us one that's what it was i think that's
what's going to happen uh the chat
things 81 says yes
uh they are going to be there and 19
says no i think it's pretty safe to say
naughty dog is going to be i don't know
why that's not 100 to zero what's going
on here
since i'm in the yes percentile
i don't know why i'm gonna need this hey
i'm up there too like hey hey nah
naughty dog naughty dog will for sure be
there like that's not that's not that's
not if they aren't there something
something was bad something something
bad happened something bad happened
that's all um
last one right at it yeah we we all know
what's next man
boys
it's saint monica hustle
saint monica studio gonna be
at this event
santa monica studio 1000 they will be
there not only will they be there we get
a release date for god of war now i
haven't quite figured it out yet
my head will tell me that they were
released the same time that they did the
last time how they released then i
believe it was april
of 2018 i might be wrong on that i think
that i think they released in april
my heart is telling me that they won't
release that close to horizon forbidden
west and that they release later on in
the year when they have a big fall game
in september
i
hope they're going to be there i i
actually got into a discussion with
people
and
i said
if
god awards not at this event
throw the whole event in the trash yeah
that's the yeah that's the whole event
in the trash because to me
this is the key reason people are coming
to this event is they want to see
something on god of war
uh we do got a two dollar super chat
from flame uh
hope we see that kojima game abandoned
there we're definitely gonna talk about
that here in a second after we get
through the first party we're gonna uh
go over all the third-party
possibilities and i'm assuming uh wack
abandon is gonna be there too in that
conversation in some way shape or form
uh but i do wanna point out that
i think a lot of people were expecting
god of war to be here i think sony's
expecting god of war to be here and i
think if they don't have god of war here
it's it's an automatic l automatic out
like i don't want to hear no excuses of
anything else uh i don't hear nothing
the game's got to be here or i am going
to be
pissed
corey ballock had just tweeted out some
things in regards to like the upcoming
showcase event
it's it's safe to say that sony santa
monica would be there
it's not even do we get a release date
though why is it they just show
another logo
i think we get i think we get a release
i think we get a window i think we do
the window and i think the window's
going to be fall i said september i
don't
i'm not going to necessarily go back on
that i still think september
if horizon's coming out i think you give
that some time to grow and breathe and
because you know that that's a top tier
franchise as well but you keep that away
from god award you don't you don't put
those two on top of each other like that
so this is the most one-sided poll i've
had so far
hustle as it should be is saint monica
studio the goat going to be there
94 percent said yes
and six percent said no all right pat
yourself on the backs the yeses because
the yeses is a go
so okay
all right so now that we got this uh
what's going on no more oscar so let's
talk about random stuff that we can
easily see here you know the third party
stuff timed exclusives put all these
together but i do want to put a caveat
on here after this we're going to talk
about that one drop the ball moment that
doesn't matter what that the whole show
could be [ __ ] but they dropped this bomb
and now it's fixed the whole show for
you and it's all good now
if it is one of these second party third
person things i want you to hold that
back don't say it so okay
stuff like abandon final fantasy 16 etc
etc
what do you expect here because i
personally feel like this is where the
bulk of the show is going to be i feel
like we're going to see some call of
duty stuff we're gonna see some uh final
fantasy 16
i think this is where the bulk of the
show is gonna be especially abandoned uh
maybe even kojima in general
uh that's why i feel like this is where
the majority of the show is gonna be
what do you think
well final fantasy 16 was the one like
as when you sent me the topics earlier
like oh that's the first one that i
thought about i think we get a release
date on and i wrote this down too we get
a release date on
final fantasy
vii the remake i think we get the second
part of it i think we get a release date
for that second part
release date for the second part
yeah for the second almost a second
edition but for the second
portion of the remake i think we get i
think we get a release date for that too
um they just had the dlc with yuffie and
all that but i think we get a release
date for that um let me make sure i
don't get nothing else down here
uh in terms of third party i think that
that was it
okay so
here's my third party okay
kind of my mic to drop moment a little
bit but it's not entirely there if i see
a good trailer for final fantasy 7
remake to help i see that no i can't say
this i got to see something besides a
logo i almost went off the cliff there
and said a logo but i gotta be realistic
i'm on a c more than a logo if i see
final fantasy 7 remake part two
i'm a trip [ __ ]
god of war don't have to be that just
get me with that just give me that and
i'ma forgive them
i must still be upset but i'm gonna
forgive them uh i think we'll probably
see forsaken there abandoned better damn
be there there's no reason why bandits
not there if abandon's not there
we're gonna have to just boycott this
game in general because i have never not
been interested in i don't really like
horror games like that anyway but i have
never not been interested
this whole
abandoned debacle i think big cloud it
was streaming that's the last little
stream that he did and he couldn't get
into the demo and it's been a whole
thing with them man and listen that game
in particular has to the level that game
has to be good i'm not like i said i'm
i'm not gonna buy it but the overall
reception of that game has to be good oh
they're going
poor hassan they're going to kill you
brother and i mean literally let me
figure them since they stick you you i
don't know man some of these people they
might get they might come after that man
yeah it's not it's not gonna be good
it's not gonna be good if that game
doesn't live up to
yo that they they were hyping oh my god
they're really hyping that but you know
hey i guess that'll be there too i'm not
looking forward to another way though
all right so
here let let's talk about mic to drop
moments because i feel like okay before
mike to drop moments let's let's put a
little bit of aisle p sprinkles in here
okay
what is something in the great words of
cognitive what's something i'll piss you
off if you see at the show you see it
and you automatically are just disgusted
with the fact that they would waste your
time and that 40 minutes to put on this
damn screen that's easy um media
molecule
that that one that's not difficult
that it ain't no no need for no third
party nah they don't need to show
anything in regards to media molecule
unless they unless they say hey dreams
is going to pc all right we'll need to
hear about that
they're everything good that that'll be
something they'll be like yo you don't
need to waste time on that respect and i
say it respectfully of course
oh god some media molecule is gonna be
on my neck boy i have two versions i
don't want to see any kind of ui
i don't want to see any stats i don't
want to see any controller stuff
um for i don't want to see death loop
i don't want to see horizon forbidden
west
you have more than two wait a minute i
don't want to see any vr whatsoever and
i know they announced that i don't even
want them to say vr i want them to stay
away from that now the only time i'll be
okay with like a ui is if it's a
complete remake of the ui you know what
i'm saying like or if they have
something like maybe gifting something
that's like highly wanted that's okay to
put on there but if they go on there
just to tell me that they change the
custom menu from the left to the right
or the right to the upside down i'm
gonna be pissed i don't want to see none
of that yeah they want it now this
playstation we talking about and i say
that with all due respect to xbox but
they're not going to announce new
controllers they're not going to
announce no
ui stuff they're not even going to
announce acquisitions because i had an
acquisition now um blue point will be
purchased and they would announce that
but they're not going to announce that
anyway that's that's the blog post thing
so they're not gonna do that either i
think
what you're gonna okay so let's go to
the drop the mic moments
what is your job you just won i know i
was joking with like the eight different
ones okay
one drop the mic moment that could save
the whole show if it's going south if
it's going if it's going south for me
uncharted 5. we see nadine we see chloe
we see sam and we see nathan's though
that's for me
chloe had to come on say something it's
only chloe could say it sam would have
to be the smartest that he is and nadine
would have to be the no-nonsense ass
kicker that she is for me for me
that if we talk about something i'm
looking forward to is that uncharted 5.
just
something quick
for me
mine
is
an acquisition um
neither i don't i wouldn't say blue
point i think that's might be here
but if they come out on that stage
hustle and they say
we bought square enix
that's crazy i i'ma lose my [ __ ] and if
you think about it there's stuff that
makes sense of why they might already
own them
name name a square enix game that's
coming out on xbox like that's being
developed right now for second nope
final fantasy 16 nope final fantasy
remake nope
like
and keep in mind all the games that was
in final fantasy they're almost all out
of game pass and they ironically the
moment they leave game pass say they're
going to playstation now
yeah yes
hey
that would be dope that that would be
dope um but i mean i just have a feeling
they want to announce any acquisitions i
look forward to seeing it though i do
look forward to seeing what the with the
template is it's it's just like you know
the take two interact thing if they
announced that i won't call into work
because i won't be on twitter a whole
lot that day you know i might have to
log out of twitter don't have you know i
can't still they're gonna be a little
hot that day on twitter but
but you know
i feel like square enix is it square
enix is a public company they're getting
out a bit on that one um
they are publicly traded company
but
i feel like
i don't know if there's a legal way they
can buy public company they could
probably get like could like
controlling interest we're not going to
go too much into the stock [ __ ] again
but
i feel like if they don't buy them
they're gonna have like an exclusive
deal where all they stuff selling a
stuff from now on because it's like i
said i can't tell you too many square
enix games coming out for xbox anymore
like
you know
and then if you think about it square
enix has been really really friendly
with microsoft in terms of stuff going
to game pass
so it's like to me it's like maybe
the last minute they just try to push
everything to the side how much you want
for all these to go on game pass until
sony owns this you know what i'm saying
like
i don't know like clearly it's a toss-up
in the money that would cost a lot of
money uh for the people who think that
sony couldn't afford something like that
you're delusional uh you know just
because i'm not saying that you know
they could buy it without any issues
they would probably have to liquidate
some money
i don't know they might not have to but
the differences between microsoft and
sony is the liquid money microsoft has
is to they could buy companies like that
and i i don't know if so sony might have
the liquid money just laying around but
i don't know if they would actually
spin 80 like 50 to 80 of the liquid
money they have on one thing
like i think that would occupy traveler
dr dragon quest 11. but
how long i i i give you octopus traveler
fc violet but dragon quest 11
came out like three years ago on
playstation
i wanna i wanna represent for all of the
uh soulsborne fans out there um
60 frames patch for uh bloodborne
that that would be a that would be a
super dope moment too if the show ain't
going necessarily so good i think that
they
instill some deal well and they either
do that or they announce the sequel
either or yeah and i get that people are
coming out my throat in the chat right
now we're gonna we're gonna address you
guys individually all right we're gonna
address you individually uh anthony just
said final fantasy 13 just came to game
pass it's an old game it's not a new
game
um
let's see there's some more of some more
nonsense in here i was thinking october
travis on xbox and not ps uh pl these
deals could be made a year ago
yeah if they could have been bought way
before sony bought anything like that uh
why don't you guys put in that chat a
game that's coming out
exclusively for xbox now
why don't you tell me that i'd love to
know what's happening with the final
fantasy
xbox thing but you can you can tell me
like after we finish and i'm gonna take
it a little bit further than that
i'm gonna tell you guys
that
crunchyroll and funimation are owned by
sony
and they're ex they and if uh they're
giving game pass away if you subscribe
to these services
so clearly they're going they have no
problem working with each other
so
all i'm telling you is just because
something doesn't seem a far doesn't
mean it's not going to happen
it would take 10 to 15 billion
to buy square enix and i'm not saying
that sony could do that easily i'm
saying sony could do that if they wanted
to
i don't know if they you know
we don't know exactly how much money
that would cost
but
damn it i said drop the mic moment so
i'm saying it square enix being bought
that's my drop the mic moment appreciate
you for coming on hustle
tell the people where they could find
hustle and motivate
hey find me on my my youtube channel
hustling motivate uh
i will just say hi in the chat so what's
the game pass on playstation drop the
mic
that would be hilarious i'm not gonna
lie
that's a call-in moment i'd have to call
in that's a call-in that would be that
would be hilarious um hey you know for
those of you who are unfamiliar with me
i know you guys see me in the chat all
the time i do something called save slot
saturday i won't be doing it this
saturday because my hd or my hdmi
super 64 has not arrived yet i had to
order one so i'm playing the nintendo 64
games like i'm on my i'm on my whole
no mercy kick i'm on my whole
wrestlemania kickstarter so so on and so
forth so i'm playing those games i'm
having a great time but uh
my av to hdmi cable went out but but but
you can catch me every saturday 8 a.m
eastern standard time just going over
you know it's a news recap it's going to
be part interview addict i'm gonna hit
you up about that too so it's gonna be
part interview you know we we're having
a good time over there so it's you know
um
just you know great things from uh small
beginners
you know sick sigma sick harvest uh
magnet i believe i got that right and i
better got it right cause i beat i beat
uncharted 1 and i beat on charter 2 and
i better have gotten that right my point
is you know we all got to start from
somewhere man um thank you for having me
it's always the place
also got good content man go over there
and watch him i do my thing man do my
thing i can't wait to see you guys
reaction to um to the show cause i'm not
gonna be able to live stream it sadly
but i'm watching y'all everybody come
through if you want all right well yeah
if i'm if i'm home in a a nice manner of
time sure i will be there and i will be
camera ready and i do appreciate the
invitation man
all right and this is uh uh you know
lord attic amy ad whatever you guys in
the chat want to call me appreciate it
for coming through if i i don't think i
missed any super chats i'm pretty sure i
got them all on me all right scroll real
quick and make sure yeah okay i got them
all appreciate everyone for coming
through we're gonna be here back next
week uh you know i might bring hustle
back next week just so we could tally up
who was right and who was wrong on who
showed up in these shows
so uh
there is uh i'm assuming that's hustle's
youtube channel go click that because i
didn't click that
uh yeah definitely go click that sub to
this man because good content uh this
thursday at like 3 30 we're gonna go
live doing the uh reaction to this event
uh you know it's going to have the
majority of the lord's the only lord
that i don't think is going to be there
saul because he has to work um blaze 4k
supposed to pull up so you know that's
going to be a funny thing okay i got it
uh you know he's kind of like resisting
a little bit and i have to like like
press him on are you scared of king so
you know
so definitely pull up to that if you
guys want to every sunday at 11 a.m
right now because of football we'll be
doing the iron lords podcast and until
next week
this is gamey act we're out of